another vehicle as well with
another missile. Matthew,
appreciate the report, thank
you. Now that you report which
is going to uncover the extent
to which Moscow is conducting
the extensive campaign to take
Ukrainian children to Russian
sometimes even giving the
military training to forcibly
adopt them. Authors had
constitute war crimes, possibly
even evidence of genocide, the
report was produced by the Yale
humanitarian resource lab as
part of a state department
program for gathering evidence
of Russian war crimes. It
identifies 43 facilities that
are part of a network
stretching from the black sea
to siberia. The primary purpose
appears to be political
reeducation. Daniel Raman as a
humanitarian research lab
executive director and oversaw
the report.
>> Nathaniel, I saw that you
called this an amber alert for
Ukraine's children. Could you
explain what you mean?
>> Anderson, what I mean is
that while we know now that
these 6000 children have been
through the system, we think
the numbers are actually far
larger. We are basically
dealing with the largest
network of children's camps,
seen in the 21st century that
stretches from the black sea
all the way to the eastern
pacific coast, about 1300 miles
from Alaska. In these 43
facilities we have
four-month-old all the way to
17 year Olds. Many of which
have not been able to contact
their parents and months.
>> How is this organized who is
in charge of this, and how high
up does it go in Russia?
>> This goes all the way to the
Kremlin. The leader of the
program is a woman known as
Maria, who is under U. S.
Sanctions. She is the child's
rights commissioner for Russia.
What we identify in this report
is 12 individuals, some of
which are reporting directly to
her that are not under U. S.
Sanctions yet. Or international
sanctions, including four
regional governors. This is
very important. Russia is
running what could be described
as a twisted sister city's
program, where communities in
Russia are sponsoring
communities in Ukraine on an
individual town by town basis
to bring those children into
Russia for reeducation purposes,
including military training in
two instances.
>> In some instances they are
actually giving children,
teenagers, military training
and they are doing reeducation
in the sense of Russian focused
reeducation, they are trying to
make them into Russians, is
that right?
>> Yes. It does constitute a
potential crime against
humanity and violation of the
1998 Rome statute in the -- it
is illegal under international
law, even temporarily, to
transfer one group of children
to another group for purposes
of erasing national identity
and ethnicity. That was
actually the first trial held
against the nazism.
>> The government seems proud
of this. It is not as if they
are doing all of this in
secret. They are embracing the
says a national project, it
seems.
>> 100%. The primary audience
here for what is dubbed the
humanitarian project is
described as a performance for
Russia's domestic citizenry. At
the end of the day, this is
part of an effort to re-brand
the invasion. But what is clear
is that it is a violation of
the conventions, we are
basically talking about
thousands of children that are
in a hostage situation, where
they could be used as a
bargaining chip in any future
prisoner exchange with the
Ukrainians. And first and
foremost, the Russians have an
obligation under Geneva conduct
prevention to move to a third
party country, not to Russia.
That right there no matter how
long they are staying makes it
a war crime.
>> Correct me if I'm wrong,
some of them who may have
parents are labeled orphans and
are being adopted into Russian
families or fostered by Russian
families.
>> We found two locations
including a 70 out truck
hospital, and what the Russians
call the family center in
Moscow, where infants and
toddlers are being adopted and
fostered by Russian families.
After the invasion, Putin and
the Kremlin changed rushes
adoption law to allow for the
first time adoption of
Ukrainians. Additionally, they
added a 200 dollar a month
bonus in basically Russia's
social security system to
encourage adoption so at the
end of the day our number one
information source is the
statement of Russia's own
officials as they are promoting
the program and speaking about
it as something that they were
proud of.
>> This is truly sickening,
this is sick.
>> I have been a war crimes
investigator for 24 years and I
have worked on everything from
torture to large-scale
massacres. This has been one of
the hardest reports that I have
worked on because I am watching
a disaster that is a human
rights emergency that is going
to radiate for decades for
these children. It is happening,
and so far, there is little we
can do about it.
>> What can be done?
>> Well, we have submitted a
report to the U. S. Department
of state. They are reviewing
the information in the report
to see if there are steps such
as sanctions or other efforts
that the U. S. Can do against
these specific individuals in
this program and we will see
what the U. S. Government does.
I think that there are four
things that can be done,
Anderson. First, and most
critically is registration.
Going back to bosnia, many
recent conflicts, having a
clear internationally monitored
registration system is the
first up to reuniting families.
Second, communication. The
phones of these children when
they have not been taken in
many cases, they are
reestablishing means for them
to call home. Call mom, call
dad, it is a critical first up.
And we need international
monitors and there from the
united nations and other
international government
organizations because right now
it is only Russia's word. That
is not good enough. Fourth, and
finally, there needs to be a
movement of these kids to the
third party country as required